il est un peu plus de six heures ce
matin encadré par deux policiers
cet homme à gauche sort d'un immeuble du
quartier des grésillés il vient d'être
interpellé dans la matinée plusieurs
opérations sont menées 35 forces de
l'ordre mobilisées notamment ici au
brésil et dans la commune d'auxonne
dans un communiqué ce midi le procureur
de dijon détail le bilan des
perquisitions
elles ont permis de saisir une réplique
factice d'armes semi-automatiques une
réplique factice de pistolets
mitrailleurs un pistolet 6 cartouches de
11 mm un bâton un poing américain
un couteau et une matraque télescopique
des armes peut être celle exhibé dans
ces vidéos diffusées la semaine dernière
nous sommes le lundi 15 juin
chenôve et le quartier des grésillés
s'embrase après un week-end de tensions
avec la communauté tchétchène
des voitures sont brûlées des caméras de
vidéosurveillance détruites selon nos
informations les enquêteurs avaient dix
cibles ce matin des hommes âgés de 18 à
43 ans la plupart ayant des antécédents
judiciaires
huit d'entre eux ont finalement été
interpellés puis placés en garde à vue
ils sont suspectés de plusieurs
infractions participation à un
attroupement armé en ayant le visage
dissimulé détention d'armes ou de
munitions ou encore transport d'armes en
réunion
en moins d'une semaine c'est donc la
troisième opération dans le quartier des
grésillés
lundi déjà neuf personnes avaient été
interpellées